The following
content is provided
under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue
to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: OK.
So what we are talking about
is actually matrix elements.
If you want to do anything
interesting in atomic physics,
you have to copy or induce
transitions from one state
to another state.
Well, maybe that should be Hab.
For many phenomenon,
which we will
cover throughout the
rest of this semester,
spontaneous
emission, coherences,
and three-level instances, and
super radiance, all we need
is a matrix element.
And this matrix
element will just
run through all the
equations, and be
responsible for a lot of
interesting phenomenon.
And for most of the
description of those phenomena,
we don't have to know where
this matrix element comes from.
The only thing we
have to know, there
is a non-seeable matrix element
which drives the process.
And as you know,
the matrix element,
with an external field, is
called the Rabi frequency.
And a lot of physics just
depends on the Rabi frequency.
But what is behind?
The engine behind the Rabi
frequency is a matrix element.
So in the unit I started to
teach the week before spring
break, we talked
about matrix elements.
And for H, for the Hamiltonian,
we used the coupling of an atom
to the electromagnetic field.
And then we calculated,
what is the matrix element
induced by the electric field?
We made the dipole
approximation.
And that's your plain, vanilla,
generic dipole operator
which can connect two states.
But we also consider,
what happens
when we go beyond the
dipole approximation,
and we found extra ways
of copying two states?
For instance, we can
copy two states which
have the same parity with
a quadrupole transition,
or we can couple them with a
magnetic dipole transition.
So these are other ways to
get into matrix elements.
For most of the
course, you don't
have to understand what
is behind the matrix,
and you just know,
there is a number
which drives the process.
So what I want to finish
today is to discuss--
and these are called selection
rules-- which tell us,
when are those numbers,
when is this matrix element
which couples two
states, when is it zero,
or when is it non-vanishing.
And what is helpful
here is, well,
as always in physics,
use symmetry.
And if you have an
operator, let me give you
examples immediately.
But just think for a moment
about the electric dipole.
The electric dipole is
the position operator R.
And you want to know, can the
position operator R induce
a transition between two states.
The way to analyse it is
now in terms of symmetry.
And for symmetry,
which is always
fulfilled for isolated
atoms, is angular momentum.
Angular momentum is a
conserved quantum number,
we have rotation symmetry.
So therefore, we want to now
understand matrix elements
in the language of
rotation symmetry.
And therefore, we don't want to
use a precision operator x, y,
or z.
x, y, z do not have
the rotation symmetry.
We want to use linear
superpositions of x, y,
and z-- I'll give you an example
in a moment-- in such a way
that the operator becomes
an element of aesthetic
of a spherical tensor.
And spherical tensor, I
gave you the definition
in the last lecture, the
element of spherical tensor, Ln,
is defined by-- well, I connect
it with something you know,
that it transforms
on the rotation,
like the spherical
harmonics, ylm.
So it is pretty much for an
operator, what the ylm, what
the spherical harmonics
are for wave functions.
I think I can do it more formal.
And Professor Schwann
knows much more about it.
I think these are elements of
the rotational symmetry group,
But I don't want to go there.
So what I mean by that is the
following, that if you take
the position vector r, you
can expand it into a basis,
which is x and y.
But if you use the spherical
basis, x plus/minus iy.
Then what appears are
the spherical harmonics.
So in that case,
it's rather simple.
The position vector has
actually in this representation
components which
you can even see
are the spherical harmonics.
And therefore, we transform
like the spherical harmonics.
Or just to give you
another example, if you
have the operator, which is
responsible for the quadrupole
transition, well,
you get the gist,
it's a product of
two coordinates.
So therefore, it's a
spherical tensor of rank two.
And it so happens,
but I'm not deriving
that, it is a superposition of
two components with Lm quantum
number, 2 plus 1, 2 minus 1.
So that's how we
should think about it.
So, we want to ask, we want
to extend the operator,
into operators which
have rotational symmetry,
and these are those, or
these are those three.
So instead of using the
vector Cartesian coordinate,
we use its spherical components.
And with that, we can
take this expression
from the last
lecture, and rewrite
it using the Wigner-Eckart
theorem into a way which
allows us to immediately
formulate selection rules.
So [INAUDIBLE] and primer
are the quantum numbers
of the state, except
for angular momentum,
so matricing about principle
quantum number of the hydrogen
atom.
And we want to copy from
a total angular momentum J
prime to total angular
momentum J. Actually,
we want to copy from J prime,
M prime to a state, JM.
And what the Wigner-Eckart
theorem tells us
that we can factor
out the M dependence.
The M dependence just comes
from orientation in space.
So M is just how you orient
wave functions and vectors
and space.
And you can sort of write this
matrix element as a projection.
And this is nothing else than
the familiar Clebsch-Gordan
coefficient.
And the Clebsch-Gordan
coefficient
for coupling the initial
state, JM, or to-- let me
put it this way-- to start with
the initial state J prime, M
prime, we have the L and
the M of our operator.
And that should result
in a total angular
momentum of J and M.
So we retrieve
again the formalism
of the addition of
two angular momenta.
Sometimes, you
have two particles
you couple into angular
momentum and ask,
what is the total
angular momentum
of the composite particles?
But what we do here for
this selection rule,
we have the initial
state, we calculate
with the angular
momentum of the operator.
You can think the
operator is a field which
can transfer angular momentum.
And then, of course,
the final state
has to fulfill angular
momentum conservation.
But one source of the
momentum is now the operator,
is the external
field, is the photon,
or the microwave drive,
whatever you apply.
And yes, this
Wigner-Eckart theorem
allows us to write the matrix
element as a reduced matrix
element.
Which really decides
whether the transition
is non-vanishing or not,
times a factor which is just
the orientation of the wave
function and of the operator
in space.
So for the Clebsch-Gordan
coefficient,
we have a simple selection rule.
And this is that for
the [INAUDIBLE] number,
the M of the final state has to
be the M of the initial state,
plus a little M of the operator.
And for both the Clebsch-Gordan
and the reduced matrix element,
we have the triangle rule.
Well, if you couple two
angular momentum vectors
to a final angular
momentum, the three vectors
have to form a triangle.
And the triangle rule says that
some-- let me write it down,
and then you recognize it-- that
the angular momentum construct
by the field has to fulfill
the triangle rule that J prime
and J can be connected.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: What is this symbolic
meaning of the double bars?
PROFESSOR: It's just
how, in many textbooks,
the reduced matrix
element is written.
It's nothing else
in a matrix element.
But, you know, plus
the y that I looked
at in the quantum
mechanics book.
But what happens is
these are not states.
J and J prime are not states.
They have an independence.
So we've taken out
the independence.
So this is sort of a matrix
element between a state which
may have been stripped
of its independence.
So maybe, I don't know
if that's 100% correct,
but if you have the
YLM in certain states,
you have an e to
the IM and M part.
And this has probably
been factored out.
So these are not really states,
and the double line just
means it's a reduced matrix
element with the meaning I just
mentioned.
It's a standard way of
factorizing matrix elements.
And yeah, that means
reduced matrix elements.
So in other words, when we
talk about selection rules,
we want to use
the representation
of spherical tensors, because
the spherical tensor, the rank
of the spherical
tensor, just tells us
how much angular momentum
is involved in the photon,
is involved in this transition.
So maybe just to
give you a question,
so if I were to do a
multipole expansion,
and I have an octupole
transition, what is now
the angular momentum
transferred by a photon?
STUDENT: 3?
PROFESSOR: What?
PROFESSOR: 3, yeah.
The dipole is L equals 1.
Quadrupole is spherical
tense of rank 2.
L equals 2, so it's L equals 3.
Now, can a photon transfer
three units of angular momentum?
Can an atom get rid of
three units of, let's say,
orbital or spin
angular momentum.
We start in a state which
is J prime equals 3.
You need one photon,
and you go to a state
which is J prime equals 0.
Is that possible or not?
We don't have
[INAUDIBLE], but do you
want to volunteer an answer?
What's the angular
momentum of the photon?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Well, be careful.
The photon has an
intrinsic angular momentum,
which is like the
spin of the photon.
That's plus/minus 1.
But just imagine that
you have an atom,
and the photon is not
immediate at the origin.
The photon is emitted a
little bit further out.
Then, with reference
to the origin,
the photon has orbital
angular momentum.
And that's what
we're talking about.
In the multipole expansion,
we fall in powers of x, and z,
and y of the spatial
coordinate of the electron.
And that actually means we're
going away from the origin.
And if you emit something
which is away from the origin,
you have orbital
angular momentum.
So, yes.
An octupole transition
is exactly what I said.
It means a photon is emitted,
and it changes the angular
momentum of the atom left
behind by three units.
That's what we
really mean by that.
And that's what we mean
by those electrodes.
The question that
you should maybe
discuss after class
is, what happens
if you detect this photon?
Is that now a
supercharged photon,
which has three units
of angular momentum?
Is there something strange
in its polarization?
Think about it, and if
you don't find the answer,
we can discuss it
in the next class.
OK.
So this is the classification.
Let's just focus on
the simple examples.
We have discussed electric
dipole and magnetic dipole
radiation.
These are induced by vectors.
Remember, E1 is
the dipole vector.
For M1, the matrix element was
by the angular momentum vector.
So
These are vectors.
And that means
the representation
of the spherical tensors,
or the quantum numbers
are the same of the Y1n.
And so for dipole
radiation, whether it's
electric or magnetic, we have
now with the dipole selection
rules, which pretty
much save you
at one unit of angular
momentum to state
B. Can you reach
state A with that?
And these selection rules are
that you can change the angular
momentum between initial
state by 0 and 1.
This is the triangle rule.
And delta m can be
0 and plus/minus 1,
depending on polarization, which
we want to discuss in a moment.
So in angular momentum,
electric and magnetic dipoles
have the same
selection rule, where
when it comes to the
question of parity,
we've already discussed that.
That an electric dipole connects
to a state of opposite parity,
whereas, the magnetic
dipole connects
two states of the same parity.
And of course, this comes about
because L is an axial vector,
and R is a polar vector, which
have different symmetry when
you invert the
coordinate system.
The one higher multipole port
transition, which we discussed,
was the electric quadrupole, E2.
And the spherical
tensor operators
for the quadrupole
transition, I gave you
already the example of, let's
say, xz, products of two
coordinates, because we went one
order higher than the dipole.
They transform as Y2m.
And therefore, we
have selection rules
for quadrupole transitions,
which tell us now
that we can change the total
angular momentum up to 2.
And also, delta m can
change up to two units.
And again, just to
emphasize, because people get
confused all the time.
When we talk about a
quadrupole transition,
we mean absolutely
positively a transition
where one photon is emitted.
If you fully quantize
the field, there
is one creation
operator of the photon.
It's one photon
which is created,
and this photon carries
away the angular momentum
we've just specified.
Questions about that?
Let me conclude our
discussion of matrix elements
by talking about something
which is experimentally
very relevant.
And this is how
selection rules depend
on the polarization of light.
And I only want to discuss
it for electric dipole
transitions.
So when we wrote down
the coupling of the atom
to electromagnetic radiation,
we had the dipole operator,
but we also had,
of course, the mode
of the electromagnetic
field, which
was characterized by a
polarization epsilon.
So until now, when I talked
about selection rules,
we discussed this part.
But now we want to see how
it effects polarization.
Well, the epsilon, for instance,
for circular polarization--
we'll talk about linear
polarization in a moment--
has this representation.
So this is the unit
vector of the polarization
of the electric field when
it's circularly polarization.
And now remember, we
take this vector r,
and expand it in
the following way.
So if you multiply now the
operator r, or the matrix
elements created by
this vectorate operator,
by the polarization, you see
that one circular polarization
checks out this component.
The other circular
polarization projects this out.
And later, we'll talk about that
linear polarization projects
that out.
So when we said that
we have matrix elements
for dipole transition,
which can change
angular momentum, or the
incremental number, by minus 1,
plus 1, and 0,
this is now related
to the polarization
of the light,
either the photon
which is emitted,
or when we use circularly
polarized light,
we can only drive this
transition, that or that,
because the scale of
product of the polarization
vector and the matrix
element project out
only one component of
the spherical tensor.
So if you look at
the expansion above,
we realize that the left- and
right-handed circular light
projects now out
the spherical tensor
operator, T1 plus minus 1.
And since it's circularly
polarized light,
and therefore, we find
this election rule
that delta m, the Z component,
the Z component of the angular
momentum, changes
by plus/minus 1
when the circular polarized
light is sigma plus or sigma
minus, right-handed
or left-handed.
OK.
So this is responsible
for circular polarization.
These are selection rules for
circularly polarized light.
Let me conclude by
discussing the case
of linear polarization.
Well, when we ask
linear polarization,
if we ask for linear
polarization along x or y,
well, it's linear polarization,
but we should regard it
as the linear superposition
of sigma plus and sigma minus.
So in other words, if you have
the quantization axis along z,
and you use light which
is polarized along x or y,
the way how the light
talks to the atom
with symmetric operators
is that the light
is a superposition of
sigma plus and sigma minus.
So what we have so far is,
so we had here the light key,
the propagation of the
light was along the z-axis.
But now, we want to look at
the other possibility that z,
or the quantization
axis, is parallel
to the polarization
of the electric field,
which would mean that the
quantization axis is usually
defined by an external
magnetic field.
If you're talking about the
situation that the electric
field of the electromagnetic
wave is parallel
to the magnetic field, then
with this polarization,
we peak out this spherical
tensor component, which is z,
which is r times Y1,0.
And that means that this
polarization of the light
induces a transition for
which delta m equals 0.
And this is referred
to as pi light.
So maybe if that got
confusing for you,
let me just help
out with a drawing.
We have our atom here, which is
quantized by a magnetic field
B. And if you shine light on
it, we have the electric field
perpendicular to
the magnetic field.
So this would be x and y.
And the natural way to describe
it is by using x plus/minus IY.
And we have selection rules
where delta m is plus/minus 1.
But alternatively, we
can also shine light
along this direction.
And for the electric field,
which was perpendicular to B,
we retrieve the previous case.
We have superpositions of the
sigma plus and sigma minus.
But the new case now is that
the electric field is parallel
to B. And then, we
drive transitions,
which have delta M equals 0.
So these are sigma plus and
sigma minus transitions.
And this here is what is
called a pi transition.
Anyway, it's a
little bit formal,
but I just wanted to
present it in this context.
Questions?
STUDENT: I have one slightly,
maybe, basic question.
When we talk about polarization
in all these matrix elements--
so for example,
photon [INAUDIBLE],
right-- these are single
photons [INAUDIBLE] elements.
And so when we talk
about shining a laser,
it has a polarization.
But we don't talk
about polarization
for single photons.
Or do we?
PROFESSOR: Actually, we
talk about-- the question
is, what is the polarization?
Do we talk about polarization
of single photons,
or polarization of laser beams?
Well, let me back
up and say, we talk
about polarization of a mode
of the electromagnetic field.
We will always expand
the electromagnetic field
into modes.
And the mode is
the polarization.
It may happen that
at some point,
a photon is emitting a
superposition of modes.
But in the most
straightforward description,
we always do a mode analysis.
And often, we simplify
the case by saying
that the atom
interacts only with one
mode of the
electromagnetic field.
And maybe in the case
of spontaneous emission,
we then sum over all modes.
But for each mode, there's
a specific polarization.
And it doesn't matter if this
mode is filled with one atom,
or with a laser beam, with
a classical electromagnetic
field, which corresponds
to zillions of photons.
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
does it always
end up being
electrical polarization
in this case, then?
Like because if
it's many photons,
then there's a lot of
[INAUDIBLE] for each of them,
or each of them
individually-- I don't know.
PROFESSOR: No, it depends.
If you have an atom, and it has
one unit of angular momentum,
and it spontaneously
emits a photon,
if the photon is emitted
along the quantization axis,
it can only be sigma plus.
If it's emitted in
the other direction,
it has to be sigma minus.
Now if you go at strange
angles, then at this angle,
you overlay it with
different modes.
And you may now find
photons in a superposition
of polarizations, because
we have several modes which
are connected with this
direction of emission.
I think if you write it
down, it's pretty clear.
It's just sort of
projection operators.
And for spontaneous emission,
we sum over all modes.
But for me, I always think
about-- we can always
think about what a single
photon does by saying, well,
if I'm getting confused
about a single photon,
let me figure out
what many, many, many
identical photons would be.
And that would mean,
instead of a single photon
in a certain mode, I
release a beam in this mode.
And then, suddenly, I
can think, classically,
I know what the
electric field is such.
And then you go
back to the, what
is the electric field
of a single photon,
and usually make the connection.
So I think at least
for the discussion
of matrix elements,
transitions, angular momentum,
I don't think you ever have
to distinguish between what
single photons do and
what laser beams do.
But there are important
aspects of single photons,
non-classical aspects, which
we'll discuss in a short while.
Other questions?
OK.
That's all I want to say
about selection rules.
So with that now, we can
simply take the matrix element
and run with it.
So in this lecture
and on [INAUDIBLE],
I want to talk
about basic aspects
of atom-light interaction.
And what I want to
talk today about it
is the two important cases
when an atom interacts
with monochromatic
wave, or when it
interacts with a broad spectrum.
In one case, when I
say monochromatic case,
you may just think of the
best laser money can buy.
Very, very sharp.
Very, very monochromatic.
When I talk about
a broad spectrum,
you may just think about
black-body radiation,
which is an ultra
broad spectrum.
And they're two very
different cases.
And some of it is just
related to Nancy's question,
that if you have
a broad spectrum,
we're always talking
about many, many modes,
and they will be
incoherent, and they
will be irreversible physics.
Whereas for monochromatic
light, everything
is a pure, plain wave, and
everything is coherent.
So we want to sort of
talk about that first.
And then later this week,
I think on Wednesday,
we will talk about
spontaneous emission.
But right now, we focus
on the simpler case,
where we drive the system with
electromagnetic radiation,
which is either
narrow-band or broadband.
But let's just start
with a cartoon.
We have an atom.
And for that discussion,
all we need is two levels.
And all we need is
that the two levels
are connected by
some matrix element.
And the basic
phenomenological situation
is that we have one atom,
which sits in a vacuum.
So we have volume, V, of vacuum.
And what is important
now is that the walls
of the imaginary boundary
of what defines our vacuum
is at low temperature.
And low temperature means that
the atom will irreversibly
decay into the ground
state with a lifetime tau.
And that means that
in some picture,
the excited state
is the broadening,
which is broadened by
the natural lifetime.
And in our discussion,
we assume--
and this is what I said with
the cold walls of the vacuum--
that the energy
difference is much,
much larger than the
relevant temperature.
And this is very well fulfilled
for our standard atomic system.
The typical excitation
energy, even
for atoms with loosely bound
electrons, as the alkalis,
is two electron volt,
which corresponds
to a temperature
of 20,000 Kelvin.
And even at the rather hot
temperature, definitely
hot temperatures, in The
Center for Ultracold Atoms,
but the KT at room
temperature corresponds
to 25 milli-electron volt.
So therefore, when we
have an atom in isolation,
this is what we find.
We find an atom which
will irreversibly decay
to the ground state.
And the fact that
it irreversibly
decays to the ground
state is really
an inequality between energies.
If you will talk about
a hyperfine transition
or something, there
may be a possibility
that we have an excited state,
which is thermally excited.
But in the following discussion,
when we drive the atom,
and when we look at
spontaneous decay,
we always assume that the
thermal energies are so small,
that we really assume an atom
sitting in a cold vacuum.
Actually, it's your next
homework assignment,
where you will
consider, what are
the effects of
black-body radiation.
And you will actually
find out in your homework
that they are non-negligible.
So yes, there are corrections.
But you will also find out
that the corrections are rather
small, or it takes a long time
before black-body radiation
induces any
observable transition.
OK.
So I'll just try to be a
little bit formal here.
Give you sort of a sketch
of an atom in a cold vacuum.
Ground state is stable.
Excited state,
irreversibly decays.
And now, we want to bring
life into this situation.
Now we add light.
And the light-- and this
is now our discussion--
has a [INAUDIBLE].
And we want to
distinguish the cases
of narrow-band and
broadband radiation.
So it's clear that
if the bandwidth
of the light, the
only scale-- well,
we have the scale of omega.
But that's a huge scale.
The only smaller scale,
which is given by the atom,
is the natural linewidth.
And depending, in
which case we are,
we talk about
narrow-band excitation
and broadband radiation.
And once the linewidth is
much narrower than gamma,
we don't get any
new physics when
we assume perfectly
monochromatic light.
So once we are much
smaller, we're really
discussing the case
of, well, we can
neglect the spectrum
broadening of the light source.
Or in the other case, when
we have broadband light,
we can pretty much
make the assumption
that the light is
infinitely broad,
and what matters is only the
spectral density of the light.
So in a pictorial
representation,
if this is the
frequency omega, we
have the atom with the
natural linewidth gamma.
Narrow-band means we are
much sharper than that.
And broadband means
really wide distribution.
So if we have
broadband light, it
doesn't really matter
what the total power is.
If the light is
very broad, there
can be infinite
power in the wings,
but the atoms don't care.
What matters when we
have broadband radiation
is the quantity called
the spectral density.
And that's what we
need in the following.
Which is, let me just
give you the units.
Which is energy per volume
and frequency interval.
So we can talk about the
spectral density as of omega.
Or alternatively, when we
have a propagating beam,
we don't want to
talk about energy,
we want to talk about intensity.
So it is intensity per
unit frequency interval.
Which would mean I of omega
is the energy density,
multiplied with
the speed of light.
And that becomes energy
per area and time.
So that's the flow of energy.
But because we are
talking about board light,
it has to be normalized
by the frequency interval.
In contrast,
monochromatic radiation,
it's sort of one
monochromatic electric field.
And we will specify it by
the single frequency, omega,
and the electric
field amplitude.
Which when multiplied
by a matrix element
becomes the Rabi frequency.
Or we can characterize the
light by the intensity I.
But then it's an
intensity which has
the units of energy
per area time.
It's not normalized to
any frequency interval,
because we have assumed that
the frequency interval is 0.
So if you now have a description
how these two forms of light
interact with the
atom, at this point,
and we come to that
later this week,
we have to make an
assumption that we
are looking at
times which are much
smaller than the time
for spontaneous emission.
So if you now, in a
perturbative sense,
expose the atom's monochromatic
or broadband radiation,
unless we have included
in the description
the many, many modes for
spontaneous emission,
we are limiting ourselves
to a very short time.
This is, you would say,
a severe description,
because atoms emit photons
after a short time.
But we already capture,
without considering
spontaneous emission, a
lot of different physics.
And we can nicely
distinguish between features
of monochromatic and features
of broadband excitation.
OK.
So let's start out with the
case of-- give me a second.
OK.
So if you look at the two cases,
in the monochromatic case,
we will discuss the
idealized situation
of an atom interacting
only with a single mode.
And what we will find out is,
we will find out that now,
in the optical domain,
we will find actually
equations for the
two-level system which
are identical to what
we discussed earlier
when we discussed
spin [INAUDIBLE]
in a magnetic field.
So in that sense,
a two level system,
driven by a laser system,
will behave identically
to a spin driven by
a magnetic field.
Shouldn't come as a surprise,
but I will show that to you.
But I can go over
that very quickly.
The board-band
case will actually
follow from the
single mode case,
because what we
assume is broadband
means many, many modes.
And then we do an averaging
over many single modes
by assuming random freeze.
But I also want
to show it to you
because I picked
my verbs carefully.
You have many, many
more things, but we
assume that there
is a random phase.
When we talked about one
photon emitted into a angle--
it maybe responds to
a question earlier--
this photon may be in a
coherent superposition.
This is not many modes
in a broadband wave.
Many modes in
broadband wave means
that there is no correlation
whatsoever between the modes,
and all we will be
able to talk about is
an IMS value of
an electric field.
But anyway, the result
is sort of predictable,
and I wanted to tell
you what I'm aiming for.
But it's now really worthwhile
to go through those exercises
and look at what
happens in perturbation
theory for short times when we
have monochromatic radiation,
and when we have
broadband radiation.
So the first discussion
will show Rabi flopping.
I don't know how
many times we have
looked at Rabi oscillation.
But these are now
Rabi oscillations
between two electronic states
covered by a laser beam.
And I want to show you
how this comes about.
And when I said strong
driving, well, we
have only a limited time window
before spontaneous emission
happens.
We have to discuss
the physics we
want to discuss in
this shot time window.
And if you want
to excite an atom,
and see Rabi oscillation
in a short time,
you better have a
strong laser beam.
So this is why the monochromatic
excitation that we discussed
will pretty much automatically
be in this strong coupling
limit.
OK.
So what do we have?
We have a ground,and we
have an excited state.
We have a matrix element.
We know now where it comes from.
And we have a monochromatic
time dependence.
In perturbation
theory, we build up
time-dependent [INAUDIBLE]
amplitude in the excited
state, because we
couple the ground
state with the
off-diagonal matrix
element to the excited state.
And we have to integrate
from the initial time
to the final time.
We have the time dependence
of the electromagnetic field,
and we also need
the time dependence
of the excited state.
So when I integrate
now over t prime,
I take out the ground
state amplitude,
because we're doing
perturbation theory,
and we assume that for
short times, needing order,
the ground state amplitude is
one, as prepared initially.
So this in integral can
be solved analytically.
Some of you may remember
that the minus 1
has something to do with the
lower bound of the integral.
And when we discuss the easy
polarizability, we said,
this is a transient, and we
neglected it for good reasons.
But now, we're really
interested in the time evolution
of the system, so now
we have to keep it.
OK.
We are interested in the
probability in the excited
state.
So we take the above
expression and square it.
And we find the well-known
result, with sine squared,
divided by omega minus omega eg.
OK.
So this is pretty much
just straightforward,
writing down an
analytic expression.
But now, let's discuss it.
For very short times, and this
is an important limiting case,
the probability in
the excited state
is proportionate
to times squared.
And this is important.
We're not getting a rate
which is proportional to time.
We're obtaining something
which is time square.
And the proportionality
to t square
means it's a fully
coherent process.
So whenever somebody
asks you, you
switch on a strong
coupling from a ground
to the excited state, what is
the probability in the excited
state?
It starts out quadratically.
The linear dependence-- famous
golden rule, [INAUDIBLE]
or such-- only come later.
This is a very
universal feature.
And even if you use
broadened light,
for a time window,
delta T, which
is shorter than the inverse
bandwidth of the light,
talking about
Fourier's theory, you
don't have time
to even figure out
that your light is broad
and not monochromatic.
For very short times,
the Fourier limit
does not allow
you to distinguish
whether the light is
broad or monochromatic.
So what I just derived for
you, an initial quadratic
dependence, is the
universal behavior
of a quantum system
at very short times.
Because it simply says the
amplitude in the excited state
goes linearly in time, and
the probability, quadratic.
OK.
So this is for a
very short times.
But if you look at it
now for longer times,
we have actually-- we'll
see the atomic behavior,
and these are Rabi oscillations.
But there is one caveat.
So we have derived.
However, we have derived them
only perturbatively by assuming
that the ground state
has always a population
close to 100%, which
means we have assumed
that the probability
in the excited state
is much smaller than 1.
Otherwise, we wouldn't
keep the ground state.
And this is only fulfilled
if you inspect the solution.
The solution is
only self-consistent
if you have an off-resonant
case, where the Rabi
oscillation only comes from a
small fraction of the ground
state population of
the excited state.
Of course, you all know
that Rabi oscillations,
this formula, is also
varied on-resonance.
And you can have
full Rabi flopping.
But I want to make a case
here, distinguish carefully
between monochromatic radiation
and broadband radiation.
For that, I need for
perturbation theory.
And therefore, I'm telling you
what perturbation theory gives
us at short times, and in
terms of Rabi oscillations.
STUDENT: So you're
saying we assume
strong coupling with respect
to the atomic linewidth,
but weak coupling with respect
to the resonance, for instance,
in [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: It's
simple, but subtle.
Yes.
So what we have is,
we assume we switch
on a monochromatic laser.
Since we do not include
spontaneous emission, which
will actually damp out Rabi
oscillation-- we'll talk about
that later-- we
are only limited,
we are limited here
to short times, which
are shorter than the
spontaneous decay.
And now, I gave you
one universal thing.
At very, very short times,
it's always quadratic.
It's a coherent process.
So that's one simple,
limiting, exact case
you should keep in your mind.
But now the question is, if
you let the time go longer,
something will happen.
And there are several options.
One is, if times go longer,
spontaneous emission happens.
OK.
We are invalid.
The other possibility is,
when time gets longer,
and we are on-resonance, we
deplete the ground state,
or [INAUDIBLE] perturbation
theory doesn't deal with that.
But if we are off-resonance,
we can allow time
to go over many Rabi periods
and observe perturbative Rabi
oscillations.
So this is how we
have formulated it.
We do perturbation
theory of the system
without spontaneous emission.
And eventually, we
violate our assumptions,
either because spontaneous
emission kicks in,
or because we deplete
the ground state
when we drive it too hard, or
if we go too close to resonance.
But the later
assumption, of course,
that we can't drive it hard,
as you know, is artificial.
We can actually discuss
the monochromatic case.
Not just in perturbation theory,
but we can do it exactly.
STUDENT: I want to
go back again to--
PROFESSOR: And this is
what I want to do now.
But first, we can go back.
STUDENT: So when we are
talking about non-B resonance
and B-resonance, so if
we decrease the detuning,
then we are getting
close to resonance.
So again, this gets invalid.
But if we increase
the detuning, we
could exceed the
spontaneous emission rate.
So then, we won't see any
Rabi oscillations again,
because, at those time
periods, this oscillation
would [INAUDIBLE] detuning.
So to observe Rabi
oscillations, we
have to be at times
more than the detuning,
or more than
[INAUDIBLE] detuning.
PROFESSOR: Oh, yeah.
Of course.
STUDENT: So the detuning has
to be less than [INAUDIBLE],
but more [INAUDIBLE] that we
are still [INAUDIBLE] resonant.
PROFESSOR: No.
The detuning has to be larger
than the natural linewidth,
because then the Rabi
oscillations are fast,
and we have Rabi
oscillations which
are faster than any damping
due to spontaneous decay.
That's an image we
are talking about.
So in the limit of our detuning,
you can detune very, very far,
and you never reach the limit
of our perturbative abode.
STUDENT: Yes.
OK.
PROFESSOR: Anyway, I
want to do perturbation
theory of the broadband case.
And the broadband case
will be an incoherent sum
over the single mode case.
So this is why I had
to bore you with,
what do we get out of
perturbation theory
for the monochromatic case?
Of course, you know already
that in a two-level system,
we can do it exactly.
And I just want to
outline it, mainly
to introduce some notation.
So our Hamiltonian
here, which couples
the ground in the excited state
is given by the dipole matrix
element, the electric
field vector,
and we call this
the Rabi frequency.
And then we have a sinusoidal
or co-sinusoidal frequency
dependence.
And all I want to
do is to show you
that a two-level system driven
by an electromagnetic field
is identical to spin 1/2,
which we discussed earlier,
and then we are done.
There is one technical or
little trick we have to do,
which is trivial, but
I want to mention it.
So if you want to compare
directly with spin 1/2,
we are now shifting
the ground state
to half the
excitation frequency.
In other words, just to make
the key analogy with the spin,
usually we say for an electronic
transition, we start at 0,
and we go up.
But now we shift things
that the zero of energy
is in the middle between the
ground and the excited state.
And then, it looks like the
excited state, we spin up,
the ground state, we spin down.
So with that, our Hamiltonian
is now excited, excited,
minus-- so all I've done
is I've shifted the origin.
And the coupling, using
our definition of the Rabi
frequency is couples
ground and excited state.
And excited ground state.
These are the two
off-diagonal matrix element.
And the time dependence
is cosine omega t.
So we are now very close to
exploit the correspondence
with spin 1/2.
Because after shifting
the ground state energy,
this is the z component
of the spin operator,
the [INAUDIBLE] matrix.
And this here is
the x component.
So therefore, for driving
an electronic transition
with a laser beam,
we have actually
spin Hamiltonian, which
has the standard form.
So let me just write
it down, because it's
an important result.
The Hamiltonian for driving
and dipole transition
with a linearly
polarized laser beam
corresponds, or is identical,
to the Hamiltonian for spin 1/2,
in a static magnetic field
along the Z direction,
which causes a splitting
between spin up and spin down.
And the splitting
is now omega eg
plus a linearly
polarized oscillating
field along the x direction.
And you probably remember that
when we discussed the spin
problem, what we
liked actually most
was that we had a rotating
magnetic field, because it
made everything simpler.
And we are doing that
now by formally writing
the [INAUDIBLE] polarized
field as a superposition
of left-handed and right-handed,
or counter-rotating
and co-rotating magnetic field.
So let me just do that.
So we have the Z part.
And now, instead of having
just sigma x, cosine omega t,
I add sigma y,
sine omega t, and I
subtract sigma y, sine omega t.
So now we have shown
that there is something
in addition to the spin problem.
We discover when we had a
rotating magnetic field,
that we have two components
here which rotate.
And these are the co and
counter rotating magnetic fields
in the spin problem.
And the counter rotating, you
remember in the spin problem,
we solved the problem
exactly by going
into a frame which rotated at
the Larmor frequency, which
becomes now omega eg.
And the co-rotating term
became stationary on resonance
in this rotating frame, whereas
the counter-rotating term
rotates at a very high frequency
in this frame at the Larmor
frequency.
So if this frequency, if
you fulfill the inequalities
that the co-rotating term
is close to resonance,
or in other words, we
are close to resonance,
and we are not using an infinite
intensity of the laser beam,
that we broaden everything
in co and counter
rotating terms of
boson resonance.
So if you fulfill
those two conditions,
then we can neglect
the last term.
And this is the rotating
wave approximation.
So in other words,
in the spin problem,
we can always assume
we haven't circularly
polarized the rotating
magnetic field,
and we have an exact solution.
I say a little bit
more about it later.
But in many situations, when
you excite an atom with a laser
beam, you get both terms.
And usually, you proceed
by neglecting one term,
and by making the rotating
wave approximation.
will, in one or two
lectures, discuss
whether there are situations
where the counter-rotating term
is exactly 0 due to angular
momentum selection rules,
but that's a
separate discussion.
In many situations, it cannot be
avoided, and it's always there.
It's actually always
there to the point
that when I talk to
some colleagues and say,
I can create a
situation, an atom, where
the counter-rotating
term is exactly 0,
some colleagues
reacted with disbelief,
and then eventually
felt that the situation
I created for angular
momentum conservation
was somewhat artificial.
But we'll get there.
It's an interesting discussion.
But anyway, just remember that
for magnetic drive, if you
use a rotating
magnetic field, you
don't need a rotating
wave approximation.
Everything rotates
at one frequency.
But usually, when you drive a
two-level system with lasers,
we usually have an extra term
which needs to be neglected.
OK.
But if you do the rotating
wave vapor approximation,
we have now exactly
the situation
we discussed for spin 1/2 in
a rotating magnetic field.
And then, the same equation
has the same results.
And then, our results for
spin 1/2 are now as expected.
Rabi oscillations without
making any assumptions
about perturbation theory.
So this is an exact result
for the initial conditions
that we start in
the ground state,
and the initial population
of the excited state is 0.
And as usual, I have used here
the generalized Rabi frequency,
which is the quadrature sum
of these matrix elements
squared and the detuning.
OK.
A lot of it was to get ready
for the broadband case.
So that's-- yes, we have a
little bit more than five
minutes.
So, so far, we have discussed
the monochromatic case.
What I really needed
as a new result,
because I carried over
for the board-band case,
was a perturbative result.
But I also wanted to show you
that the perturbative result is
one limiting case of the
exact solution, which I just
derived by analogy to spin 1/2.
OK.
So we just had the result
that in perturbation theory,
for sufficiently short
times, we discussed all that,
that the excited state amplitude
has the following dependence.
So this is nothing
else than-- I want
to make sure you
recognize it-- Rabi
oscillations at the
generalized Rabi frequency.
The generalized Rabi frequency
is simply the detuning,
because it's a
perturbative result.
In perturbation
theory, you don't
get power broadening, because
you assume that your drive
field is perturbatively weak.
So therefore, the
Rabi oscillation,
our now Rabi oscillation
where the Rabi frequency,
the generalized Rabi frequency,
is delta the detuning.
And this is just rewriting.
Let me just scroll up.
This is this result here.
I wasn't commenting on it.
But this is nothing
else than the detuning.
Look.
I'm just reminding you what you
get from perturbation theory.
Power broadening is not
part of perturbation theory.
OK.
So this is our
perturbative result.
And now, we want
to integrate over
that because we have a broadband
distribution of the light.
So what we have to use now is
the energy density, W of omega.
The electric field is
related, the energy
of the electromagnetic field, is
1/2 epsilon the energy density
of the electromagnetic field,
is 1/2 epsilon naught times
the electric field squared.
Well, if you have many modes,
we add the different modes
in quadrature.
And we still have
the same reaction
between the electric field
squared and the total energy.
But the total energy is now
an integral over d omega.
We integrate over frequency
over the spectral distribution
of the light.
So this is how we go from energy
density to electric feels.
But now, we want to
evaluate this expression.
And what appears
in this expression
is the Rabi frequency.
Well, what we have
to do now is we
have to go back from
the Rabi frequency.
We assume linearly polarized
light in the x direction
to the electric field.
And that means, now,
that when we-- OK.
We want to now take
this expression,
and sum it up over all modes,
which means we integrate over,
we write the Rabi
frequency squared
as an electric field squared.
And the electric
field squared is
obtained as an integral over
the spectral distribution
of the light.
So this means we will
replace the Rabi frequency
in this formula by an
integral over the energy
density of the radiation.
We have the matrix element
squared as a prefactor.
I just try to
re-derive it, but I
think the prefactor is
2 over epsilon naught.
So, yes.
With that, in
perturbation theory,
the probability to be
in the excited state
is-- let's just take
all of the prefactors.
Now, I change the integration
variable from omega
to detuning, we just
go from resonance--
we integrate relative
to the resonance.
So our energy density is now
at the resonance, omega naught
plus the detuning.
And we have this Rabi
oscillation term.
OK.
So this is nothing else than
taking our perturbative Rabi
oscillation formula,
which is coherent physics,
and indicate over many moles. .
I'm one step away
from the final result.
If the energy density is
flat, is broadband-- so
for the extreme
broadband case, we
can pull that out
of the integral.
And then, we are left only
with this function, F of t.
And you can discuss
this function, F of t,
is a standard result.
And we have seen
many discussions
in perturbation theory.
If I plot this
function, versus delta,
we have something
which has wiggles.
Then, there is a maximum,
and it has wiggles.
The width here is
t to the minus 1.
And the amplitude is t squared.
And this is the excited
state amplitude squared.
So if we integrate
that over delta,
we get something
which is linear in t.
Something which goes as
t-square, and has a width 1/t.
Yes, time is over.
So the function F of t,
which is under the integrand,
starts out at short
times, proportion
to t squared, as we discussed.
Maybe my drawing
should reflect that.
But then it becomes linear.
So for long times, the function
F of t becomes linear in t
and the delta function
in the detuning delta.
This is what you
have seen many times
in the derivation of
Fermi's golden rule.
I'm running out of time now.
I'll pick up the
ball on Wednesday,
and we'll discuss that result
and put it into context.
But the take-home
message-- and what I
really wanted to show you is
that we do have coherent Rabi
oscillations.
And by just performing
the integral
over this broad
spectrum of the light,
we lose the Rabi
oscillations, and we
find rate equations,
Fermi's golden rule,
and excitation probability
proportional to t.
And we have done the transition
from coherent physics
to irreversible physics.
This is all hidden
in this one formula,
but I want to fully explain
it when we start on Wednesday.
Any last second
question about that?
Cody?
STUDENT: It looks
like we're integrating
right over the point to where
perturbation theory becomes
an exact, because we're
integrating over delta
equals 0.
And that's the most
important part.
PROFESSOR: We are
integrating over it,
but we are integrating over
it with the [INAUDIBLE].
So therefore, since
we have-- perturbation
theory remains valid, actually.
Perturbation theory
remains valid,
as long as the excitation
probability is less than one.
So I have not put a
scale on it, but we
can go from a
quadratic dependence
to linear dependence.
As long as the probability
of being in the excited state
is smaller than 1, perturbation
theory is exactly valid.
So I think what
confuses you here
is, we can do
resonant excitation.
The broadband includes
But for sufficiently
short times,
we reach the rate
equation before we run out
of [INAUDIBLE]
perturbation theory.